[Musica]
sarà perché siamo al cinema ma mi viene
a mente una frase di di nanni moretti
che ci invita a considerare che le
parole sono importanti
allora partirei esattamente dalla parola
che è stata scelta per questa settima
edizione del ted di padova che è
identità
allora identità viene da idem significa
lo stesso la stessa cosa se volete
trovarci una parentela immediata pensate
a identico allora l'identità delle
persone anche dei luoghi e le identità
possono mischiarsi e noi possiamo essere
figli in qualche misura figli dei luoghi
che frequentiamo nei quali siamo nati
vedremo nel corso di questo breve di
questa breve riflessione che faremo
insieme la faremo insieme perché
cercherò di sollecitare una riflessione
in voi rispetto al vostro vissuto
rispetto alla vostra storia al luogo in
cui siete nati al luogo che avete
maggiormente vissuto come impronta
badate che il tema del codice genetico
della città vale per le tre che vi
proporrò ma in generale vale per i
luoghi che abitiamo quindi parleremo di
trieste di venezia e di padova potremmo
parlare di salisburgo o potremmo parlare
di parigi o di londra e via così dicendo
e dunque guardiamo al tratto identitario
quel che fa peculiare quel luogo
iniziamo partendo da una città di fresca
fondazione che è una caratteristica del
tutto atipica in italia questa città di
fresca fondazione è trieste
trieste nasce intorno alla metà del
settecento ma si forma veramente lungo
l'ottocento
questo è un portone è questo qui è un
altro portone incontreremo tre porte nel
corso di questa traiettoria allora in
questo portone a due battenti troviamo i
due numi tutelari di trieste i due
simboli quel che caratterizza la storia
e il destino di quella città da una
parte c'è mercurio dall'altra parte c'è
nettuno all'incontro tra i due
dio del commercio l'uno dio dei mari
l'altro ci sta una città che nasce come
porto come porto dell'impero e tutto
deve al fatto di essere stata scelta
dall'impero asburgico come porto di
quell'impero senza il porto quella città
sarebbe rimasta un borgo un borgo di
salinari e di pescatori nulla piu di
questo
dunque l'identità di trieste è città
porto venezia venezia una città con una
densità di storia di cultura di deposito
talmente ricco che potremo perderci
allora dove l'identità riconosciuta nel
mondo ed è un fattore simbolico di
venezia
vedete questa è l'altra porta alla
seconda questa è la porta di accesso
privilegiata lungo mille anni di storia
di venezia
noi ci entriamo attraverso il ponte
translagunare che è stato costruito nel
ma i cortei regali degli ambasciatori
degli alti prelati arrivavano in bacino
di san marco e dovevano transitare
attraverso i due stipiti della porta che
sono le colonne di piazzetta san marco
e allora da una parte a lato sinistro ci
sta a san teodoro il primo patrono della
città
e dall'altra vediamo qui in questa
inquadratura il leone di san marco il
leone di san marco e il sigillo mondiale
di venezia riconosciuto ovunque quindi
la dimensione identitaria di venezia è
la sua internazionalità il suo essere
riconoscibile agli occhi del mondo
veniamo a padova
anche qui c'è un tema di porte questo è
il caffè pedrocchi che nello scritto di
stendhal
siamo intorno al 1830 viene definito
come il più bel caffè d'europa e fateci
caso è vero è più sontuoso più ricco a
un progetto più pieno di qualsiasi caffè
in europa di quelli parigini come di
quelli viennesi come di quelli londinesi
ma noi noi padovani voglio dire lo
definiamo il caffè senza porte così come
diciamo che questa è la busi basilica
del santo senza nome e questo è il prato
senza erba
questo è un punto sul quale occorre
riflettere perché se padova si definisce
per sottrazione
evidentemente manca di una sufficiente
riflessione di una sufficiente
consapevolezza di sé e possiamo dire in
massima serenità che mai giotto mai
donatello sarebbero transitati per
padova
se padova non fosse stata caratterizzata
antecedentemente a loro
dall'insediamento dell'università che
quest'anno compie otto secoli infatti ma
senza l'università non ci sarebbero
state le condizioni per generare
ricchezza per attivare una vita
culturale
talmente intensa talmente dinamica da
attirare due artisti sommi e ho portato
due esempi ma ne possiamo portare a
decine come per l'appunto giotto e
donatello l'università è la calamita che
attira a padova galileo galilei che dice
di aver trascorso a padova li 18
migliori anni della nostra stagione
ossia della sua vita intera perché a
padova aveva trovato le condizioni per
esercitare in libertà
la scienza per intraprendere
un'avventura culturale che altrimenti in
altre parti d'italia e d'europa più in
generale gli sarebbero state precluse
ma se andiamo a guardare l'albo degli
degli iscritti degli studenti o dei
docenti ci troviamo copernico ci
troviamo anche due che suonavano la
tromba 1 a suo modo e l'altro a suo modo
ancora e cioè eustachio quello delle
trombe e falloppio altre trombe intendo
dire che nelle sale dell'università è
transitato un fiume di cultura ed i
protagonisti della cultura mondiale che
hanno reso ricca e caratterizzata
l'identità di padova
veniamo ai giorni nostri pensi possiamo
pensare davvero che padova potrebbe
candidarsi ad essere sede dell'agenzia
europea del biomedicale se non avesse
questi otto secoli di storia alle spalle
potremmo immaginare che si candidasse a
attrezzare un ospedale che richiederà un
investimento di un miliardo di euro ma
il contato se non ci fosse questo lungo
percorso questo lungo tragitto
e noi che stiamo vivendo questo tempo
così sfidante e mi riferisco
naturalmente il covip senza avere
sperimentato l'importanza delle
competenze plurime quindi quelle
ingegneristiche così come quelle della
scienza medica
così come quelle della statistica
sperimentate non tanto tempo fa e sto
parlando della primavera scorsa
potremmo immaginare di avere un
cruscotto più attrezzato più forte più
solido guardate che non lo stiamo
sostenendo noi c'è stato riconosciuto
mondialmente basta andare a guardare la
rassegna stampa di quest'ultimo anno
allora fondamentale aver preso per mano
il bandolo della matassa
perché altrimenti rimane molto intricata
quella padovana e il bando la matassa è
uno l'università
lì c'è il codice genetico se tu
[Musica]